Olivia Coleman has gone one further
ladies and gentlemen because in her new
show she had her daughter in her in the
things like Russian dolls
and your dumb plays a role and this is
the night manager the new series that
you guys in her yeah
[Laughter]
okay it's a UK thing
I got it I got it but they they wrote
the bump in yeah when I first went to
meet to the director and I just found
out I was pregnant and I thought I can't
lie because it's going to become obvious
and so I said I was pregnant and Susanna
went oh okay so um she said I almost to
talk to talk to the producers and and so
this is my preciousness
Lucky's he's not here because then I can
tell you it's really good okay
and then and I was going and um if you
remember Fargo Francis McDormand was
pregnant and it really added to it I
think it would help sort of fingers
crossed and they went away and came back
and said yeah okay we can do pregnant
yeah uh yeah we'll ride it in so let's
go because you didn't have to carry a
bag in front of yourself it was so big
there was there would have been no
hiding it and then and also I was
waddling quite a lot and Susanna and
once said could you uh could you walk
let's go pregnant
[Laughter]
so this is uh the night manager uh
coming out in BBC One next month see
that I look like someone like a I've
snuck into the back of Shop
it's in like a model shoe spherical
beings
when they left the paper cups on the
mantelpiece in Downton
person like
she didn't say it but but she said I was
like it kind of does
[Music]